in general I get a screenplay maybe six
weeks or six months ahead of time and I
hope that I'm able to make some notes
and give the director of those notes
sometimes I've done that and the
director says I don't like these notes
and then we part early and that's good
because that's a way of sort of testing
the water before you actually dive in
but in general the the notes are
received with interest sometimes they
actually do some of the things that I
suggest but that's not a criteria it's
just a way for me to start getting into
the story by writing by thinking about
it already in writing notes I also time
the screenplay which not all editors do
I would recommend it because it's
another way of sort of fitting yourself
inside the suit of this film you to time
a screenplay accurately you have to do
it two times at least and to do that you
actually have to visualize everything
that's on the page many problems I think
in films come from the fact that
something hasn't been thoroughly
visualized the some quark anyway but
that's another thing that I do to help
get purchase on this material yeah I
have something that's called the rule of
six that that's more about actually when
you're doing the editing it was an
attempt to answer the question in some
ideal let's say even platonic world what
is a perfect cut from one shot to
another the strange thing about editing
is
and cutting from one shot to another is
that before we actually started doing it
which was only a hundred and twenty
years ago it might not have worked it's
the idea of actually splicing two
different shots together and having the
audience accept that as a continuous
reality is surprising it's surprising
that it works so this was a hit list
really of criteria and the top criteria
was emotion which is very difficult to
quantify or qualify even how did how
does this transition from one shot to
another make you feel you have to keep
your fingers on that emotional pulse as
an editor and not really ever let it go
you your grip sometimes loosens a little
bit but it's like riding a horse you
have to always hold the emotional reins
in your hand sometimes you actually have
to jerk it a little bit but hopefully
not too often after that is story does
it help tell the story after that is
rhythm and you can think of shots cut
together as a kind of rhythm track the
syncopation of the cut which is a big
shift I mean the cut lots of things
change at that point and that rhythm has
to integrate itself within the rhythm of
the actors and the rhythm of the
camerawork other other things that are
determining the rhythm of the shot and
then there are three slightly less
significant things which you have to
have a good sense of where the audience
is looking in the frame because they're
not looking at the whole frame all the
time they're choosing to look at areas
and that determines how good a cut is
and then the so-called 180 degree rule
does it look like two people are talking
to each other when do you violate that
when do you say
I don't care I'm working on a
documentary at the moment and
documentaries for the most part let go
of that the least-significant you can
tell I'm going kind of down in
significance the last thing is what you
might call three-dimensional continuity
which is did that person get up from the
chair and walk across the room in a
convincing way or was it confusing where
they are in the early days of film that
they paid a lot of attention to that and
you can look at the films stylistically
over the 20th century and you can see
that we've let that wander well we were
all film students Francis actually was
at UCLA and he was four years older so
he was I think he'd already graduated by
the time I was in film school George
Lucas was also going to USC as I was and
it was hopeless to think that we could
work in Hollywood and we were told this
off over and over by those teachers in
fact the the first thing that the
teacher said on the very first minute of
the first day was you can still get your
money back you can get out now and go do
something that will earn you a living
because there's no jobs for you 1965
which is when this was was and still is
the low point of Hollywood production
fewer films were made then than ever
since and the teachers who were all 20
years older than us saw this slope
clearly and they thought it was just
going to keep going and so they sort of
pitied us why are you doing that when
Francis and George and I started
American zoetrope up in San Francisco
the mood was let's get out of this
Hollywood thing and make films the way
we made student films we'll just make
them bigger that was the dream and it
went through many rocky period
and films that didn't commercially
anyway succeed until the Godfather and
that was the first big film that that we
all worked on and that became a big hit
Godfather was the first time that I'd
ever worked in Hollywood in the the
bowels of the machine so to speak and I
took chances and discovered that in fact
even though it's this big machine you
can actually do these tricky things and
it's the scene where Michael kills so
also in the restaurant which happens
about midway through the film and
Francis and Nino Rota had decided to
have no music throughout the whole scene
and the other unusual thing was that it
was a fairly long scene the restaurant
scene and a lot of it was in Italian
with no subtitles I mean that's a risky
thing to do today let alone 40 something
years ago so it threw the audience a
curveball
they didn't quite you know what's going
on there so there's no music which
usually guides you and you don't
understand what they're talking about so
you have to pay a lot of attention to a
body language and expression and the
quality of the voice but I thought well
let's do something with sound that might
help the moment and because I grew up in
New York not far from where that
restaurant theoretically was I knew that
there were a lot of subway trains that
in that part of New York had come up
above ground and so they were elevated
tracks and those trains make up tequila
or noise because the whole structure
vibrates and I thought maybe we could
introduce that sound and let it go away
as if a train passed and then bring
another one in that little slightly
louder and then as the scene goes on
four or five times I can't remember this
train sound which has no visual
equivalent there's nothing that
introduces this sound you don't know
what it is really unless you kind of
Intuit it at the very end of the scene
Michael comes out of the restroom and
Clemenza had told him come out blasting
in other words come out of the room and
shoot them dead and he doesn't and so we
the audience are wondering consciously
or subconsciously what is he not gonna
shoot them he sits down and he listens
and now we think what's but in the
background this train sound gets louder
and louder and louder and then it starts
to screech as if the train is turning a
corner or putting on the brakes and as
it gets louder we're moving closer and
closer to Michael's face and Al Pacino
is doing a really interesting thing with
his eyes kind of looking around and then
suddenly he stands up pulls out the gun
and shoots sollozzo and the sound stops
which means it wasn't a real sound it
wouldn't a real sound wouldn't have
stopped like that so it the the sound of
the bullet kills the screeching sound
and some some audiences are not even
aware that there is that sound they
interpret the sound as a we're listening
to the neurons in Michaels brain because
he's making this incredible
life-changing decision not only to kill
two people but to kill the dream that he
expressed at the beginning of the film
which is he's not going to be part of
this family
it's adventuresome particularly for the
time because there's nothing visually
that corresponds to it except the
interior state of the actor the
character and it that was a lesson to me
that even on a big Hollywood film where
you think everything is just sort of by
the
book that you can throw these curves
into the soundtrack and actually enhance
the film as a result I was mainly
influenced by the films that were being
made in Europe and Japan India Kurosawa
such abject ray Bergman Fellini Godard
all the 1960s and they sort of charged
me up and that was not only mine but our
goal I would say the same for George
Lucas and Francis Coppola we were all
driven to make films not by so much by
American films but by world cinema if
you had drilled into our minds and said
what do you really want to do it would
be to make films in the United States
but to bring world cinema
in as an influence I love to collaborate
and I've worked on a number of films
where I am one of three editors or one
of two editors one of the real
advantages of digital filmmaking is this
enhancement of the collaborative
back-and-forth you you could do it in
the old days if there were mistakes then
it was hard to sort of pull back you'd
had to reconstitute the film and you
would there were these splices in there
and the expense of reprinting the films
was considerable but it did happen but
the tendency was not to happen but with
the digital stuff there's there's no
reason not to do it the situation is so
different today a machine that could
edit film in Hollywood back then the
movie olla cost the equivalent of forty
two thousand dollars today
whereas today you can take everyone has
a laptop or something or even an iPhone
and you can get editing programs for
free and you can download stuff for free
that the upside of what people have
today
is easy free access to incredible tools
that we just didn't have the downside is
that everybody has access to so the the
amount of competition and how to make
yourself heard in the noise of the
culture today is is that's problematic
but you know you can do something great
and put it on YouTube and get 5 million
hits and there you go you know something
will happen as a result of that
you